so migraine headaches are actually a lot
more common than many people might think
I get migraines as do twelve percent of
the US population so this video is me
looking into some treatment for
migraines and it involves some needles
in the head so if you are a little
squeamish and this isn't your thing then
you probably don't want to watch this
video just saying so the exact cause of
migraines is not fully understood but
the symptoms are described as tree
shading paint that is throbbing or
pulsing blurred vision extreme
sensitivity to light fatigue nausea and
vomiting there are preventative things
you can do when there are treatments but
for a lot of people like myself these
things don't always work for me recently
my migrants have been increasing so I
was talking to my doctor about it and he
had suggested me looking in to putting a
neurotoxin into my head this is like
Botox now though this does not sound
like the most pleasant thing in the
world it's actually something I'm
willing to consider because I do have
some experience with injections into my
scalp because of my autoimmune disorder
before the procedure
I asked family friend and respected
doctor dr. Henning of Princeton
Dermatology Associates to explain how
exactly Botox is thought to help
migraine pain mechanism of action for
Botox in the treatment of migraines is
not fully understood the neurotoxin
paralyzes muscles and it is thought that
its use in migraines is related issue
hain transmission that is reduced when
hair lies the muscles around the head so
we talked to dr. Henning and I think I'm
gonna go for it
I'm still a little nervous about some of
the risks but it seems to be something
that helps a lot of people so we're
gonna give it a shot should be
interesting it should be interesting
yeah yeah and so it was time for the
appointment the first they cleaned my
head a lot next the doctor had me
wrinkle my forehead and marked the
injection spots no time for the Botox
[Music]
the Botox is a numbing agent is pretty
incredible
surprisingly despite how this looks the
process was pretty mild and in just 15
minutes it was over two days later I
didn't notice much of a difference my
face could still wrinkle and I even had
a minor migraine on day four five days
later my face feels relaxed in a weird
way and the forehead wrinkles have
smooth
three weeks later final thoughts I would
say that the overall experience was
unexpected when looking up Botox I found
two very opposite search results half of
what I saw were more like Botox ads
where people just looked as static to be
getting shots in their head the other
half I found were tons of horrific
photos their eyebrows stuck up here
their faces frozen in this really weird
way my actual experience is simply a
boring middle ground the process was
easier than I expected I haven't had a
migraine since day four and I am loving
this wrinkle-free forehead yet surely
there are some serious things to be
aware you can actually get something
where your eyelid completely droops you
can hit like a major blood vessel or
something like that I mean there are
some actual complications that can
happen well I'm appreciative of
everything I feel very fortunate that I
have accessed something like this it's
still nothing to take lightly so that's
my review boring and in the middle but
hopefully it's helpful look at that how
ecstatic they are you see not happy
there they are loving it
who are these people
[Music]